with abortion back in the news you've
probably been hearing lots of
pro-abortion arguments they come fast
and furious and repetitively and the one
thing they all have in common is that
they're all quite wrong and stupid
so now i'm gonna go through every
pro-abortion argument
and debunk them all in about four
minutes or less hopefully all right so
four minutes on the clock
let's go through them argument number
one a woman has the right to choose
answer no nobody has a universal right
to choose we all agree that some choices
must be prohibited the question is not
if women should be able to choose
generally but if they should be able to
choose to intentionally destroy innocent
human life if you say they do then you
have to defend that choice on its merits
you can't defend the choice based simply
on the fact that it is one two
pro-lifers want to control women's
bodies answer no the body in dispute is
not the mothers the question again is
whether the body of the human in her
womb can be intentionally destroyed the
child's body is the one at issue here
and we as pro-lifers are the ones trying
to defend it three pro-lifers are only
pro-birth they don't care about babies
after they're born answer you have no
data or evidence to support that stupid
claim besides our position is that
babies in the womb have moral worth
equal to babies outside of course we
believe babies outside have worth that's
the whole basis of our argument our
assertion is that babies in the womb
have worth and that's based on our
contention that babies and all people
outside have worth our argument hinges
on the comparison between humans inside
and outside the womb and our contention
is that there is no inherent difference
in these groups aside from their
physical location four the fetus is just
a clump of cells answer we're all clumps
of cells some of us are far clumpier
than the average infant none of that is
relevant what's relevant is whether the
fetus is a distinct and separate human
entity which he is five the fetus is not
a person but a potential person answer
no he is again a distinct human entity
if this is not the definition of a
person then none of us are persons also
even if he is a potential person it
doesn't automatically follow that we
should destroy him do you believe that
all non-persons can be killed what if i
decapitated a bald eagle how would you
feel about that you see you're wrong
that the unborn child isn't a person by
definition he is but even if you were
right you'd still be wrong that's how
wrong you are six women have
reproductive rights answer this one i
agree with nobody should ever be forced
to reproduce but birth is not
reproduction conception is reproduction
by the time the abortion is procured
reproduction has already occurred seven
what about rape and incest answer that's
not an argument that's a hypothetical
rapid incest only account for about one
percent of all abortions these are hard
and rare cases they might mitigate the
individual moral culpability of a woman
who chooses abortion but they don't
change the fact that the unborn child is
a distinct human entity i.e a human
being i.e a person and therefore worthy
of the same protections the rest of us
receive we can't kill the child for the
sins of the father if you want to
execute somebody for rape execute the
rapist not the baby eight women cannot
be forced to remain pregnant they have
bodily autonomy answer no they don't
have absolute autonomy and yes they
should be forced to remain pregnant if
the other option is to kill the child if
this sounds harsh to you then consider
the fact that we already force parents
to do all kinds of things for their born
children we force them to feed their
children clothe their children care for
their children every second of the day
we impose responsibilities on parents
that we don't impose on anybody else i
am required to do things for my child
that i don't have to do for any other
human on earth if parents don't want to
fulfill that obligation they must find
somebody who will they can't simply
leave their kid on the side of the road
nor can they drown their kid in the
bathtub murder and neglect are not
acceptable parenting strategies for
babies outside the womb and they
shouldn't be for babies inside the womb
either nine fetuses aren't conscious
therefore we can kill them answer first
of all how do you know we know basically
nothing about the nature of
consciousness we can't even agree on
what consciousness is much less where it
comes from or how it works besides let's
say that they aren't conscious how does
that justify murder especially when we
know that their state of unconsciousness
is temporary should it be legal to kill
people when they're sleeping what about
a person who's in a coma but expected to
recover within a few months and if
consciousness is the measure then
shouldn't the right to life be granted
in degrees according to the level of
consciousness not everybody is equal in
consciousness a 25 year old has greater
consciousness greater self-awareness
than a one-year-old what about people
with dementia they're conscious to some
degree but it's fading so how far does
that go what's the limiting principle
here there isn't one ten finally
pro-lifers are just a bunch of men
trying to boss women around
answer not true the pro-life movement is
and has always been led primarily by
women also it's irrelevant also it's a
double-edged sword roe v wade was
decided by only men shall we overturn it
on that basis i'm guessing you'd say no
that's why that argument doesn't work
none of these arguments work which isn't
a surprise given that you're trying to
justify the murder of children there are
no good arguments for that that should
hopefully now be obvious
[Music]